[Music]
I don't and also I'm not joking him
where he does some weird to itself
Inquisition although this habit is on
his map this here you see the
teeter-totter look to the teeter-totter
oh this time I'm here
full director and run back with watch
house behind us run with it to the net
you're not on a movie
so the way this head comes up I'm in the
right place then without
[Music]
you're still doing the oh it's the same
it's right there and you do the same you
drill let's talk about my is the
appropriate space-time so that's gonna
require something else can't just be
space and time because I stuck the word
appropriate in there so do your high
school physics that means appropriate
toward a specific end in this case we
demonology
I have to be at a particular place at a
particular time to set that technique up
okay
so otherwise the technique becomes kind
of like a modified grappling technique
so you're here this is he see how to
wrestling them right and I think you're
gonna crank him up but when we're here
like that could be I'll edit like he's
good
do you see the mind change I can feel
like he's gonna come in you see right
the fight still on and who has to
leverage at this point he does he's got
those big-ass legs and shoulders
can you just tackle me forward you see
Nagi abhava is dislike box I do not put
locks on the person he falls into the
wall
do you understand that subtle difference
okay so what I'm doing is a particular
space time and he wants to get up you
see well I'm gonna be in a place where I
could do that to give it a touch you see
that rather than he's getting up for -
honey I'm not resisting for money
he's trying to get back in the fight and
I am in a place where I can't control
every Sun suddenly his ascent so boom
ah I'm over here but you will not ever
move the same eye twice and no one can
ever do the same thing twice will always
be you see the time before that was to
ten cons and this one was the kind of
sukiyaki twice to the rear but as far as
what happened whose body was the same
thing so don't try to pick anything be
here in this moment move without on
vacation same you see this is different
this is not the same position we were in
last time you see and if you when you
push it down maybe what's gonna happen
it goes past me you see an intern throw
so some rules are mine as time and space
look how I keep moving I can't stop so
there's no way it can be the black spot
it was either wrong before he moved
where I stay still or it's now wrong way
he moved and I continue to say so okay
it's not a matter of speed it's just a
matter of staying witness okay let's get
the mind okay so the my particular to
the desire right its face and I'm not
just space because he keeps moving I
must keep moving those are some basic
rules okay and in the first example I
give you which I must move in a place
that I can't control his ascent with
this with this so if I did that but that
time I was too far away you see if I'm
doing this I'm too close right so this
is the movement you see this is the
movement I have to put my spine where
that will work got it
okay then the same thing happens here I
must put his hat and my body where this
will work okay so let's find out where
that works okay
whoa draw whoa around
look look see see right there
all right I can't go like this I'm gonna
go too far and the radius of that
movement is not functioning in relation
to where is his Kazushi but somebody who
are here
you can't affect that the sushi but you
losing the mechanical advantage he's
very strong here with that short little
lever that I have okay
here this is push on that arm push hard
you you come push on them help them push
out watch the difference
wolf you understand it's just the time
for hand so one one not here okay
see that okay so that text I can't just
happen wherever I'm in the back boom
right there it's inside not at the elbow
inside so this can get around and the
other side of the leverage point you see
that not here and you turn him like that
this already got his balance
this is now aiming him you see I'm on
that side of his head right down oh you
see he's not on look down here
he's over here I get on the other side
oh my ball oh okay let's go
[Music]
I'm going to draw them here and then
using separation and then your
choreograph to get comes around is more
the initial sabaki grease that angle we
always want boom I drop it in shikaka
he's going to be on a curve and I stamp
with the curve that's what the tech on
this okay see if you can see that so
move the tech con was not used to take
him it's used to keep me in the back the
fine booth you see he gets up and I move
over China making for positioning okay
not turn in for turning stay cool stay
up with him you see I'm in the back do
because he gets up and there it is
[Music]